hey you you said something also that was
on twitter i just i just if i didn't
look at this i wouldn't have found all
these little gems but you said that
supernatural almost didn't hire you or
cast you because
you felt like they thought you was too
stupid
no not i felt dude i was with the actor
talked to me
the other day so this is really funny so
i'm sure you kind of remember these days
but for those who are listening in the
early 2000s if you were auditioning if
you were if you looked like
michael rosenbaum or jared padilla
it was very like they wanted to be like
broody you're like brooding like like
sort of like ugh
like oh i'm thoughtful i'm pensive and
so i went in and i was on gilmore girls
and i was doing the whole brooding like
uh i'm james dean because that's what
worked back in the day when you were
auditioning
and uh the the
critique or response came back to my
manager spiel who i talked about earlier
uh and it was like well
uh crippy's looking for an intellect
like a david decompany type and so
[Laughter]
which which wasn't directly saying like
well we think jared's stupid uh but so
my manager had to call and go like hey
listen he missed one question and math
from sats he's a national merit scholar
he's a debate champion like he's just
okay give him that note let him come
back wait a minute wait a minute you
were your sats were that high
they were all right yeah i mean i missed
one question math
so you got like what a 13 1400 on your
sats
yeah 1490 i think are you freaking
kidding me but i only took when i was a
sophomore but you're a genius
i'm not a genius man i don't think i
don't think uh i mean that's incredibly
bright
i don't think i got half that
i'm not kidding talk about i don't want
to sit here i know that my fans get
upset when i call myself
not you know call myself stupid or
whatever but i'm not saying i'm stupid
i'm just like
i was never great with tests man i see
that's that's the thing is that i i did
well in tests the smartest most
interesting intriguing people i know
by and large didn't do well in tests
because their brain just goes from a
different angle and so
like i i feel like this is me beating
myself up or something uh but i i
i would rather be around an interesting
person who has questions about the world
than somebody who got a 1600 okay good
good then we can hang out then
let's go but but
i would love to celebrate with you i'd
love to go up those spiral staircase
right there i'd like to spend the night
there at the padalecki homestead
come over